hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich mache heute ein türkisches
bisher und zwar gibt es wer war der
tatort ist ein gries kuchen der wirt
getränkt mit etwas zucker sirup
eigentlich ist es immer relativ süß aber
ich habe ein bisschen weniger zucker mit
drin dafür etwas mit zitrone und so
schmeckt das ganze eben auch sommerlich
leicht uns das ganze kann man richtig
schön vorbereiten gern auch schon einen
tag vorher und kann es dann einfach
schön eiskalt genießen
und wir müssen jetzt dazu erstmal den
sirup erstellen und dann den teig aber
ich sage jetzt einfach mal direkt alle
zutaten also für den sirup brauche ich
eineinhalb wassergläser zucker
eineinhalb wassergläser wasser und etwas
zitronensaft und ich werde jetzt auch
alle zutaten in gläsern abmessen aber
zeigt euch dann oder bzw schreibe ich
auf dem blog die genauen mengen für den
teig brauche ich drei eier da ich mir
gerade bis backpulver mit rein gerutscht
aber ich nicht schlimm
eine prise salz etwas vanille extrakt
ein t class zucker 1 t klasse also
sonnenblumenöl drei viertel t glas milch
zwei gläser hartweizengrieß sechs bis
sieben ich habe sieben esslöffel mehl
ein päckchen backpulver und später
brauche ich das ist jetzt nicht für den
teig aber später für obendrauf brauche
ich noch mal ein glas kalte milch und
wie gesagt haben jetzt zuerst diesem
zuckersirup und bei türkischen rezepten
ist ebenso da wird es meistens in
gläsern gerechnet aber wie gesagt
schreibe ich euch beide varianten
einfach direkt in ein blog mit rein gebe
ich den sogar in einen topf gemeinsam
mit dem wasser und es wird jetzt erstmal
verrührt
und während es hier auf dem herd auf
kochen kann nehme ich mir meine zwei
zitronen sind bio zitrone und treibt
auch schon mal die schale ab die gebe
ich aber mit in den teig und kann dann
anschließend den saft mit zum sirup
gehen
wenn der zucker sirup anguckt dann gebe
ich noch den saft von 1 zitrone mit dazu
manche geben da jetzt auch nur so eine
kleine spritze mit rein
aber ich find zitronig schmeckt auch
besser deswegen gleich die ganze zitrone
und jetzt lasse ich das ganze noch mal
so etwa eine minute kochen und dann ist
der sirup auch schon fertig und ich kann
ihnen auch gleich um füllen damit er
gleich abkühlt und ich ihn später dann
auf den prüfungen geben kann
und jetzt zeige ich euch einen trick wie
ich das immer ganz schnell ganz kalt
kriege und zwar bis jetzt hier zwei so
kühlelemente aus dem gefrierfach stelle
an der metallschüssel drauf also eine
richtig schöne große damit ich eben viel
fläche ab und gehe ist das jetzt hier
rein
da kann nämlich dass sirup hier schön
abkühlen bis ich jetzt nämlich den teig
vorbereitet und den teig eben auch
backen die zeit nutze ich nämlich jetzt
ich habe jetzt hier schon die
zitronenschale mit drin
jetzt kommen die eier mit rein auch das
alles und das an allen extrakt
und natürlich auch der zucker
und jetzt wird es richtig schön cremig
gerührt und in der zeit kann ich schon
mal eine springform die hat einen
durchmesser von 24 cm mit backpapier
auslegen
jetzt gebe ich die zwei flüssigkeiten
mit rein milch und öl
also dieses drei viertel glas milch
lasst es ganz unteren wobei mittlerer
stufe dann könnt ihr auch schon mal
backpulver vermischen damit das
backpulver sich gleich schön verteilt
jetzt kann ich hier nämlich gries und
mehl und backpulver auch noch mit rein
gegeben
es gibt hier auch andere rezepte meine
mama macht es zum beispiel statt mit
milch mit joghurt und ich glaube sie
nimmt sogar gar keinen mehr
aber ich finde das rezept ist ein super
rezept vor allem wenn man hat gar kein
mädel nimmt dann bindet es nicht so
schönen krümelt der kuchen später so ein
bisschen und ich finde sich für die
gelingen sichere variante und auch sehr
lecker das kurz untere
und dann kann man den teig auch schon
fertig ich kann jetzt direkt in die
backform rein gießen
ihr könnt jetzt natürlich auch in den
bug rahmen machen aber da wird später so
viel sirup eingegossen also es geht auch
immer springform gut wobei ich auch beim
mohnkuchen das ganze im programm gepackt
noch als es geht beides und ihr könnt
hier jetzt auch im bug rahmen mit 26 cm
nehmen ich habe jetzt nur irgendwie
gerade keinen da keine ahnung warum ich
habe nun 24 er und deswegen mache ich
das jetzt einfach da drin
und so geht s ganz jetzt in den backofen
bei 160 grad ober und unterhitze ist
bereits vorgeheizt für ungefähr 35 bis
40 minuten also nach 35 minuten mache
ich schon mal die stäbchen probe und
eventuell brauche aber 14
und wenn er heiß ist und der sirup kalt
ist sehen wir uns gleich wieder
der kuchen gebacken und noch ganz heiß
ich habe ihn jetzt aber etwas zwei
minuten abkühlen lassen
jetzt gebe ich auf den heißen kuchen die
kalte milch einmal drüber
nur wird auch gleich eingezogen wie ihr
seht und dann kommt auch der zucker sehr
gut drauf und das jetzt auch schon
richtig schön abgekühlt noch nicht
eiskalt wie aus dem kühlschrank aber
abgekühlt und den gebe ich da jetzt auch
drauf das sieht jetzt noch ganz schön
viel aus ich habe mich auch beim ersten
mal als ich das gemacht hat nicht
getraut den kompletten sirup drauf zu
geben
aber ihr könnt wirklich den kompletten
nehmen dadurch wieder schön saftig und
bekommt auch die süße denn im teig drin
steckt ja nicht viel zucker
und derzeit ist jetzt komplett ein aber
dafür muss ich ihnen jetzt eben noch
richtig schön abkühlen lassen
am besten erstmal bei raumtemperatur
danach könnte in den kühlschrank stellen
und wenn er dann komplett kalt ist zeige
ich euch das endergebnis und eben auch
wie man installiert der kuchen ist
abgekühlt und jetzt werde ich ihn erst
mal aus der form lösen
einfach hier mit sohn mit seinem kleinen
mit einer kleinen palette an den strand
vom rand lösen und jetzt setze ich ihn
zuerst mal auf eine schöne platte denn
ansonsten bekomme ich das papier der
unternehmer weg einmal hiermit zum roten
retter drauf
und jetzt können sie ihn schneiden ganz
typisch ist es dass man ihnen rauten
schneidet und jetzt nicht wie so'n
normalen kuchen
deswegen mache ich das jetzt auch schöne
rauten meine mauer packt es auch immer
in so einem runden backblech also in
seinem text auf türkisch aber ich finde
in einer springform geht es viel
einfacher machte halt in rand lösen kann
ich
und jetzt für die raute einfach das grad
für euch hinlegen und dann eben schräg
ansetzen
und bevor ich ihn jetzt an richtig gebe
ich noch ein paar kokosflocken mit drauf
die passenden geschmacklich perfekt mit
dazu ihr könnt auch die stadt ziehen zum
beispiel nehmen
die sind dann optisch noch mal so einen
kick finde ich so mit dem grünen ihr
könnt auch beides nehmen also ganz
viertes gold
und zum anrichten nehme ich mir jetzt
natürlich ein schönes rautenförmige
stück und ihr seht jetzt auch der kuchen
ist jetzt ziemlich hoch das heißt wenn
ihr das in einer 26 reform backt oder so
eine art und 20 er wieder etwas flacher
also das könnt ihr dann eben nach
belieben machen und dann kann man das
auch schon fertig und ich finde sich
ebenso ein richtig schönes saftiges
bisher eigentlich ist ein kuchen weil es
im türkischen erzurum des erzählt wobei
wochen auch einen test aber auf jeden
fall in gries kuchen ist
und ja das rezept gibt's zum nachlesen
auf sallys - blog.de
der moralische zeitung nicht da zum
probieren ansonsten hätte das bestimmt
gerne probiert aber ich probiere den
später auf jeden fall ist extrem saftig
und ich finde auch von der zuckermenge
wirklich optimal denn ich mag selber
nicht zu süß aber zu wenig darf man auch
nicht benutzen weil dann echt nach
nichts schmeckt und deswegen finde ich
das so von der von der zutaten menge
eigentlich genau richtig und ja ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen das ist so ein typisches dass
er was man eben zum ramadan zum beispiel
macht oder auch zum opferfest also so
ein feiertags gebäck deswegen habe ich
euch die sind noch zeigen wollen kurz
vor dem ramadan fest
und ich hoffe ihr werdet es mal
ausprobieren dann schickt mir ein foto
auf facebook oder instagram und wir
sehen uns dann ganz einfach beim
nächsten mal wieder biss dann tschüss
ab juni
ja
comic mama